For pairs of sets of data, like we have in this situation, there's a special
sort of notation that we use to help us get ready to graph. So, in this column,
I have a set of values that d could equal. And then, in the column next to it, I
have a set of values that n will equal, whenever d equals the values to the
left. To show which values in either column fit together, I write them inside
parentheses together with a comma in between. The reason this helps us with the
graphing is that traditionally, the number that comes first corresponds to the
horizontal value, or the horizontal coordinate of the point that we're going to
draw. And the number that comes next corresponds to the vertical value of the
point, or the vertical coordinate. So, thinking about how ordered pairs
translate into graphing, where does the point 5,115 belong?